this group in the middle that we're
concerned with up to say 60 $65,000 in
household income yes they are the ones
we need to help and they don't get
nearly as much help as this bottom group
does Ron Haskins longtime expert on
issues concerning struggling Americans
at the Brookings Institution thanks for
being here
glad to be here so you worked with
scholars from both the left and the
right to produce a report work skills
community
restoring opportunity for the working
class tell me about the facts concerning
this group that you thought needed
attention there are a whole set of facts
the first chapter in the volume after
introduction and a bunch of preliminary
material it's about the facts on which
we built the rest of the arguments we
described roughly how many people there
are they're there the people between who
are have a high school degree but they
do not have a four-year degree they live
of course all over the United States we
show a map where they're concentrated a
number of them are concentrating areas
it won't surprise you like Appalachian
area Ohio places that have had high
unemployment in the past but these are
people who are they're making it but
barely and many of them are not going up
they're struggling to keep their heads
above water and I describing these
people having met a number of them and
visited we both visited a number of
these groups I wouldn't have society
struggling a mine aid they have not
given up they're trying they're trying
to help their kids but I do think a
number of them are pretty discouraged
and they did not expect what has
happened to them and that shows up in
the facts about what their financial
condition is and especially we have a
section on on debt and wealth which is a
affects you know net
that they're worth and for almost all
families a lot of people don't know this
for almost all families except really
wealthy families it's how much they have
in their house and so many of these
families lost their home during the
recession and they haven't recovered
completely so they have zero or close to
zero wealth and that's going to affect
their retirement and they don't have
enough money to make it up so there are
lots of issues here that we try to spell
out in that fast chapter so anybody who
reads the port report can start off with
a you know what its basics that affects
one other thing that I would mention
that I think is very important I think
there's a growing awareness of this in
the country but drugs are a big problem
and we have a great team of researchers
from Princeton who described this
problem in great detail others have as
well and we've had a number of books in
the last three or four years you have a
great expert here at AEI Sally Satele
and this group is not only expanded but
they've gone deeper and deeper in the
whole and many of them it does appear to
be hopeless and in fact they die so we
have what what the Nobel Prize winner
calls deaths of despair and we give data
on that that problem is increased
greatly and it's concentrated in the
same areas as the these working-class
families so that's another big problem
and we really don't have any good
solutions for that so stagnating wages
declining wealth exposure to drug
addiction and serious health issues a
feeling of hopelessness politics in
Washington is it responded to their
needs
it has it has not been a great response
we just passed an opioid bill as you
know maybe that'll have some effects in
the past the this kind of legislation
has not had much of an impact I think
it's a lot of people think of Washington
response and does the right thing can
will make a big difference that usually
is not the case you could have marginal
effects but over a period of years if
you have a number of good policies like
what we proposed then it could make a
difference so that's what we're hoping
we're hoping in a lot of simultaneous
changes in policy that are applied
evenly and wisely over a period of years
would have an impact on this problem
that's a local level yes the local and
state well I'm thinking the local and
state level so we apply it we do
something about opioids we do something
but wages we do something about
employment we do something about
community I think all these things have
a potential to make a difference so one
more preliminary question that we went
down to Kentucky yes see something yeah
and and get a sense of of a successful
program what do we see the most
impressive thing to me was and I love
this be in part because it was it was
undertaken by the private sector
primarily automobile companies but it's
expanded now and Toyota created a
program in which they focused on kids
who are high school graduates and we're
pretty smart it wasn't a you know kids
who are doing the worst from high school
because who are say roughly in the
middle and who do not have plans to go
to a four-year college in this of
courses right right at the heart of our
the group that Ryan cerned about and let
me say that I have followed this
research for a number of years and I
think as a nation we've made a mistake
by over emphasizing the importance of
four-year education now I think you have
to be real cautious here because I love
the idea for your education I want my
kids to get a four-year education I was
intent myself on getting them for our
education but
we have millions of kids who they're not
going to do on a four-year institution
because they're they're not prepared for
it and we have encouraged many of them
go to college and they went to college
they didn't finish they wound up with
debt so now they do both the worst of
both worlds they don't have better jobs
and they have debt from college so we
need a strategy that helps people get in
the middle there and get jobs and pay 10
or $20,000 more than the typical you
know entry-level job $10 $10 an hour job
right and we actually have pretty good
studies that show that we can do that
and this program is called Kentucky fame
and they now have started out with just
a couple of employers it was designed
primarily by employers which by the way
years of research have shown the most
successful training programs are the
ones that put then employers start and
employers run and the federal government
needs to figure out how to subsidize
them and not design a program say here's
what you have to do the employer is the
one that knowing what they need they
know the skills they need to emphasize
and that's what we saw in this program
we saw a beautiful place where they
train these kids and give them skills in
electronics in welding the kind of
things that you know where there are a
lot of jobs available and they pay you
know fifteen twenty twenty-five dollars
an hour and they have a future so that
was very encouraging and they are doing
well they've even expanded since we were
there where they're little over a year
ago so I think there are now 300
employers that are involved in that
Kentucky fame approach program so that's
the kind of thing that we talk about it
dr. Mann yes and think needs to be
incentivize by the federal government
yes so during a little bit to what
Washington can or cannot do you have
been a longtime supporter of the
something called the Earned Income Tax
Credit which tops up wages for families
with children in the household often
single mothers great yeah I think Ron
you're the one who first taught me about
the ways in which work requirements
blended with work supports can really
bring families out of poverty and has
really brought families out of poverty
we make a recommendation about another
group that's been left out of that work
support system great tell us about that
right
well I think the broader point here is
that we we we have a lot of things that
support single mothers and they would
support single fathers if they were
custodial single fathers but most of
them are not so we support we have a lot
of problems in this Earned Income Tax
Credit is one and it can be six seven
thousand dollars years so this is a very
serious benefit we spend about seventy
billion dollars on the program so this
is serious policy here we don't have
anything cooling for men we have a dinky
little 400 $500 a year maximum benefit
for them if they if they go to work and
and earn a wage so we would like to
increase that and we propose
substantially increasing that for it it
would be primarily single fathers who
would benefit from it but these are
individuals who go to work and have
earnings and are non kazuto they don't
have kids many of them have kids that
they're they don't live with and they
pay child support we actually have a
very good study in New York City we have
another one going on in Atlanta the
study from New York City this is
perfectly timed with our report by
coincidence it showed that there was
actually an increase in the number of
workers men primarily men who go to work
they have increase in earnings and they
have an increase in their payment of
child support so all three of those
outcomes are very nice it's a good thing
that happened it's a very good company
named manpower demonstration Research
Corporation demonstrated those effects
and now they have another one going on
in Atlanta we'll see if we have the same
effects there these are not huge effects
we wish they were bigger but they're
still impressive and they're significant
they're statistically significant the
this was one of those right-and-left
combination things where we tried to get
people to agree right one thing that I
think was important to me and I think it
was important to you and I wanted you to
sort of describe why it was important
was that its deficit neutral or spending
neutral yeah tell me it tell us about
that
the left seems to be less intense about
this but the members of our group on the
Left were they seem to be right where we
were you know the deficit is too big we
gotta do something about the deficit and
God knows in the long run what the
consequence is going to be we're already
in you know in the red zone we're going
to be hurt in the long run by this the
red zone in the extent that with that
the percentage of debt to GDP or the
size of our deficit is so high that
we've we've lost opportunities to
address it sooner and now it's getting
worse
well yes and and there will be
consequences that's what I mean by the
red zone especially impacts on our
connect anomic growth their number
studies that show that so we're in
danger territory and we got to do
something about it and the worst thing
is that Washington seems they are acting
like they're not aware of it they have
to be aware of it but they're not doing
anything there's no serious action there
are no serious proposals on the table
and in fact many of their proposals that
are most serious even discussed now
would increase it even more Trump has a
proposal apparently a lot of support
among Republicans to increase it by
another trillion dollars by a middle he
calls the middle-class tax cut so this
is really a very serious problem and we
wanted to at least be neutral we wanted
not to increase the debt problem so we
found revenue so we've when found
revenue offsets and we made a number of
changes in tax policy and in spending
policy to offset I'm not sure you need a
CBO Congressional Budget Office
estimates to really let you know if you
achieve that but at least it's a signal
that we were concerned about this
problem and we did something about it so
you've been in Washington a long time
Ron and you know the cliche is that
nothing ever gets done and
bipartisanship never really happens or
at least that's the cliche now is that
true no tell it's not true I think last
year we did a lot of really interesting
things we we increase the childcare
support for working families that's a
very good thing because we
to help workers we changed the the the
child tax credit which has the same
effect and helps low-income families we
passed a number of bills having to do
with education and with related issues
so there have been and all of these are
bipartisan and we also did I don't want
to bore anybody about this but I've been
following child protection issues abuse
and neglect for many years and we've
tried to have many many years now trying
to create a program that would help
States figure out ways to keep the
families in their homes from the very
beginning now this is a risky business
because most of them have been involved
in abuse or neglect so you want to work
with the families keep the kids safe and
work with the families to reduce the
problems that the families are having
so we don't have to remove the kids from
their home our history shows that if we
remove kids from the home the outcomes
are not good this is a very sometimes
you have to do it because the kids are
right you know they're physically
threatened but once you do that there
are long-term consequences and it's hard
to get the kids in a stable setting so
this new program with all passed by
Congress passed signed by the President
on a bipartisan basis signed by the
president called family first would
provide more money to the states to
design these programs if they're based
on evidence which is another I think
very strong thing and by the way as a
footnote to my response to you a lot of
the problems that have gotten support
now our evidence-based programs are to
try to promote evidence-based programs
so there have been a number of programs
in the last couple years that are both
based on evidence we have reasonably
they might be effective and they enjoyed
bipartisan support so in your judgment
bipartisan group puts together report
with a whole host of ideas
notwithstanding what we've seen CNBC or
Fox News your view would be based on
what 35 years of experience here
Washington would be there's a good
chance the way things happen in this
that good ideas do lead to better
legislation and do lead to positive
outcomes in the country yes I that is
correct and I would I am far from giving
up on this idea the one caveat he says
often takes number of years to really
penetrate you know that the Congress so
if we have a new Congress at least a new
house representatives which seems
slightly less than 50/50 now just a
guess then the Congress I see the house
will be trying to do new things and some
of them will involve spending social
policy would be very much on their
agenda so they may be looking around for
stuff like what we did and we could go
there and we might be able to present
the same ideas in the Senate let's say
that the Republicans who keep the Senate
and they might be attracted the ideas
too we had very strong Republican
members of this group as well as members
on the left so our proposals can appeal
to both sides for so just last sort of
question you've spent most of your
career focusing on people at the very
bottom yes and in advocating and
researching and describing solutions
that can help them the fact is we've had
some success at reducing poverty
absolute in child poverty in the United
States
yeah people on the left and right agree
with that and partly because we've spent
a lot of money on it
you have to admit though they don't seem
to have noticed it yes I know but the
numbers are stronger and better yeah in
terms of getting people up to that first
ladder yeah but this other group was
kind of unattended - yeah and so do you
think you'll have a chance for similar
success
now that Ron Haskins has turned as I
don't think that we'll have much of an
impact but this is a very very good
point that we've had good success at the
bottom and that's the the most basic
thing and it's good that we did that and
we've been we've reduced poverty for
sure and our programs are done and we
have shown that low-income workers are
way better off than they were in the
past so that's I think that's a success
- that the message goes forth
you got to work right and that's a good
thing because you're not going to move
up further unless you
do work but this group in the middle
that we're concerned with that you know
it from up to say sixty $65,000 in
household income yes they are the ones
we need to help and they don't get
nearly as much help as this bottom group
does so that's where our proposals are
aimed and I hope we can make some
progress and and I'm not at all
pessimistic that we could make progress
and that if we did this group would be
helped Ron Haskins thanks for being here
glad to be here thank you very much hi
everyone that's the end of our
discussion with Ron Haskins thanks for
watching and as always let us know what
other topics you'd like a AEI scholars
to cover on viewpoint and to learn more
about the working class in America check
the links in the description below